sinclair bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors on le voit
bien depuis le début de cette crise
sanitaire la france comme le monde vit
des situations inédites en termes de
confinement puis déconfinement est-ce
qu'on peut du coup critique et une
action du gouvernement qui est inédite
tout y est dit qu elle soit n'importe
quelle action politique par définition
elle est critiquable et heureusement
sinon y'a puis démocratie deux choses
premièrement vous l'avais dit dans le
reportage c'est symbolique
le principe de déconfinement a été
validé par tout le monde population et
responsables politiques
la critique et le vote majoritairement
en abstention mais aussi en opposition
avec le texte du premier ministre ne
permettra pas d'empêcher le
déconfinement mais en revanche ils
marquent une dissension la fin de cette
union nationale autour du gouvernement
donc la fracturation de cette union
nationale un impact politique fort
premièrement parce que c'est une
critique adressée directement au
gouvernement mais deuxièmement parce que
ça valide la stratégie de la première
opposante au gouvernement marine le pen
qui n'est pas au sénat parce qu'il ya
pas dessinateur rassemblement national
mais qui elle est en dissensions et qui
pointe les dysfonctionnements les
contre-vérités comme l'a dit bruno
retailleau et les les
les manquements dans la gestion depuis
le début donc en réalité c'est une même
si c'est symbolique c'est une opposition
très forte et très marqué qui vient de
se nouer au sénat vous avez voilà dit à
l'instant cette fin d'union nationale
beaucoup parlent d'une explosion sociale
aussi après le déconfinement comment
est-ce qu'on peut envisager l'après
politique de cette crise
écoutez il ya encore une fois sur le
principe du déconfinement accord il ya
désaccord sur les modalités du
déconfinement
donc deux solutions soit le gouvernement
entend il ya un certain nombre de
blocages idéologiques vous avez remarqué
que le président de la république a par
voie de presse si je ne m'abuse
réaffirmé le fait que la france aura
enfin les français auront des limites en
matière de dévolution sur le territoire
à cette fameuse limite des 100 km en
revanche les européens pour des raisons
totalement idéologique sans frontières
east libéral dans le sens le plus large
du terme c'est à dire libre échangiste
pourront se déplacer comme ils veulent
donc les européens ont sur le territoire
français un avantage que les français
n'ont pas si ce type de blocages
idéologiques continue à se produire
c'est une crise politique majeure qui va
se nouer si l inverse
le gouvernement entend enfin et réagit
de façon pragmatique alors à ce moment
là il sera possible de circonscrire la
crise et d'essayer d'apporter des
réponses ici ou là parce qu'il ya malgré
tout des avancées qui ont été positives
je crois que globalement les
propositions économiques qui ont été
faites par le ministre de l'économie et
des finances bruno le maire ont été
plutôt bien accueilli il ya à nouveau
des propositions qui ont été faites pour
aider les étudiants donc le le
gouvernement simplement à adé à des des
points de blocage idéologique qui sur
lesquels il ne veux pas revenir qui pose
réellement en termes de libertés
publiques de libertés fondamentales des
problèmes très sérieux et la question un
des cultes sur lesquels il ya des
ajustements qui sont en train de se
faire donc il faut que le gouvernement
entende qu'ils cessent de s'entêter s'il
veut éviter justement cette fronde
sociale cette crise politique majeure
qui pointe à l'horizon
alors dernière question beaucoup de
rumeurs circulent à propos de la
relation actuelle entre edouard philippe
emmanuel macron c'est que le chef de
l'état a pris la parole hier en même
temps
que edouard philippe au moment où il
était au sénat ce que ça montre une
certaine tension justement au sein des
deux hommes est ce une manière pour le
président de la république de prendre de
nouveau la main alors deux choses
premièrement cette tension existe
deuxièmement le l'épisode d'hier a été
surinterprétée en réalité edouard
philippe est entièrement dans la gestion
du quotidien
donc la gestion du quotidien ça suppose
de rappeler la dimension négative du
confinement donc c'est très alarmistes
comme constat comme description et puis
de prévenir un déconfinement qui serait
un espèce de retour à la normale
anticipées alors que ce n'est pas
possible donc forcément on a dans un cas
comme ça un langage qui est très austère
al'inverse le président qui lui cherche
à prendre de la hauteur et qui est dans
la praye confinement entièrement a
forcément un discours qui est très
optimiste et donc qui tranche avec celui
de son premier ministre
et c'est cette opposition de discours
cette opposition de point de vue de
position politique qui a marqué
finalement l'opposition entre deux
hommes dans le cas précis il n'y a pas
de jeu à lui dire de quoi fouetter un
chat
en revanche il ya effectivement
détention de fonds il va y avoir
nécessité pour emmanuel macron s'il veut
réellement préparé 2022 dans de
meilleures conditions que les conditions
actuelles va y avoir nécessité de
réfléchir à un après un après ça ne peut
pas seulement être un changement d'idée
de communication ça doit aussi passer
par une incarnation et donc un
remaniement
merci beaucoup frédéric saint clair
d'avoir réagi sur notre antenne je
rappelle que vous êtes politologue